[Applause]
your boy uh
kanye wants to run for uh president
still
and uh it has kind of been outed not
exactly
that he might be doing it as like a
third-party way to take votes away from
joe biden yeah
and um i think the funniest part about
this
this type of stuff exposes like the soft
bigotry of democrats that i don't think
that they get enough credit for
but like democrats are scared
that kanye west could take votes away
from joe biden
which means yes democrats think
black people are stupid enough so simple
massive numbers yeah to vote for kanye
west
for president now to me
i'm not black shocking but
if if if you as a black dude al
is that not insulting a little it's not
when you have people like
nick cannon publicly saying he's going
yeah but nick is just trying to get
black approval right he's just
influenced
on whom he has some people watch the
show like he has some influence
because nick does it i don't think
anybody's doing anything
i get to see a black guy wearing a
[ __ ] turban
i'm just saying or the headphones chance
the rapper he said he'd vote for him too
chance pulled that [ __ ] right back i'm
just saying that
the fact that he can take some votes
like there are people
that aren't thrilled about biden who
would just vote for kanye just because
he's on the back you have
every right to not be thrilled about
biden yeah okay he is a
corpse it's crazy that he's even running
what did he say
about latinos and black people well this
was actually really interesting what he
said because he got a lot he got a lot
of [ __ ] for this
but he was basically like black people
don't vote as a block
no sorry latinos don't vote as a block
latinos don't vote as a block black
people do
and everybody's like oh my god he's
saying that black people
don't have that what is it no that's
what he meant to say how do you say it
different types of latinos they come in
all you know different
types of groups unlike black people
who all think the same he made it seem
like it's all thoughts and not just
voting
even voting you can't say it even if
it's right
look for the most part black people vote
the same way
yeah and like what you said that's what
he meant yeah
i think and listen i've been very
critical of joe biden i'll be very
critical because i just don't think that
he's mentally there enough to be the
president of the united states of
[ __ ] america
i actually think the democrats running
him shows me that the democrats don't
want to win
i think they want trump to win in a
weird way something's going on here i do
not
it's something's very off here that
being said
um what he said is not inaccurate
black people for the majority i mean we
could just look at past elections the
majority of black people vote
democratically
latinos cubans are republican
and it's not because they hate mexicans
or whatever the [ __ ] people say about
republicans it's because
they hate communism they hate big
government especially a big government
and they associate anything close to
communism like big government
as the worst possible thing because they
went through this communist regime
so they're like [ __ ] that anything even
mentions big government or government
no we're republican all the way jorge
masvidal game brand
i think had a [ __ ] trump hat it's
cuban you can't really fault him for
that because you don't know the
circumstances that him and his family
came from
so if he's a single-issue voter which is
who got the smallest government because
i know how bad this could get
i understand that yeah okay right just
as black people are single issue voters
about
what's going to be best for black people
i'm not going to knock you for that go
for that
anybody i think all joe biden is for
democrats i don't think they want trump
to win i do think they hate trump i can
see your point
but i think they just want who they
really want to get elected as his vp
kamala elizabeth warren whatever whoever
we can't get elected
probably a female let's let this joe
biden let's have him be the face of
everything
whoever the [ __ ] is behind him going to
be running everything that's the
president
it's like george bush junior from what i
understand was like
he wasn't he wasn't making the decisions
it's rumsfeld and all these other guys
underneath him making these decisions
he's just kind of like the figurehead
that he's an electable person
got a good bloodline let's do that joe
biden hey listen he's not too diverse
moderates he'll be comfortable with joe
biden vote for him kamala or whoever
going to be
calling shots yeah i tend to agree that
i think joe biden especially at the time
was like steady hands and that he was
someone that would like do
what the party line is yup go with the
flow not cause any problems
and then they can get his vpn who will
like sell the ticket and then ideally
kind of call the shots if he has to pull
out
into his presidency that makes the most
sense yeah the only reason i give
a little bit of pushback is if they
don't
put uh kamala harris in as his running
mate
if they put someone who's an absolute
no-name
right it's a very curious move
yeah because i'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on then you're gonna have the no
name
that people are unaware of granted
kamala is polarizing at least people
know who she is
at least she's got a lot of experience
in government maybe
bad experience a lot of people are very
critical of kamala
right but the fact that they haven't
announced yet
you think it'd just be a kamala or
elizabeth whoever the [ __ ]
yeah the fact they have an announcement
is odd to me i
see it as a good thing for them like the
less biden does right now the better
so so i think sorry to interrupt but i
think the reason why we're not they're
not announcing
is they know whoever they announce is
going to be criticized yeah so they're
holding on
for as long as you possibly can exactly
that's why they don't want him to speak
it
like a basement sorry walk me through
this i'm not disagreeing but at some
point you've got to announce them you
have to announce and that's just less
time to trash the person less time go
through every single one of their tweets
less time to build up all the memes less
time to create
this is the wrong person for the job
narrative
to try to poke holes in that kamala
they've already done that with
so if you announce kamala now we already
had a year of her running right we
already went through everything we
already tried
why they're not going to pick her i
think they're going to pick that i think
susan rice was her name or something
like that
who i don't even know who the [ __ ] that
is do y'all know who the [ __ ] that is
not really not really is he trying to
that's gonna be the president
like that's crazy is he gonna is he
trying to pull a
john mccain and just get a vp like a
[ __ ] well john didn't even want her
whatever i saw a [ __ ] hbo movie about
it right basically just seemed like hey
we're going to lose this election we got
to try something
throw a hail mary basically and then it
turns out the [ __ ] knew nothing but
that's the party though
i think john didn't want it john's like
principal dude yeah but so
i i whatever that's no i don't believe
that but i'm saying
to that same line is that what the
democrats are going to try to do whether
it's biden or the party
i really don't know what the democrats
are trying to do because
whoever is the organizer of the
democratic
you know national committee or whatever
the [ __ ] it is
needs to go because all this
disorganization it's like every little
thing that they do and they support
or that they won't talk about just helps
the other side like even what's
happening in chicago right now i don't
have all the details so i don't know
exactly just from what i read is
all i can tell you from what i read i
read an article newsweek that's it a few
articles rather
what i gathered from the articles was
the guy
shoots at the cops i guess the cops
shoot him did they end up killing him no
they just injure him yeah so they shot
back at the guy yeah
the guy's still alive
and then there's riots in the street and
then looting
they go to like the fancy the fifth
avenue of chicago
and they start breaking into the tesla
store start breaking into like fancy
stores and like
just taking [ __ ] you know in a few years
the test will drive itself off the line
the only person that all this helps
is trump it's like you're handing trump
the election
literally when you're trying to convince
white moderates to vote against trump
that's who sways the election right
middle whites
yes right to the majority of the country
they're gonna make the ones you need to
tap into
you think when they see fancy stores
getting broken into that got nothing to
do
with the police shooting allegedly it's
all i read
shooting back at someone who shot at
them
and you see the tesla store get broken
all these other stores get you think
they're gonna go
you know what we need the defund the
police we need to
just do whatever the democrats say just
let the riots go no they're going
with the law and order guy yeah
everybody votes for who makes them feel
safe
yes that might be financially physically
yes
security my only push back to that is i
don't think
anyone in the democratic party is like
encouraging the rights
like that just happened as a result of
they're not my understanding of this
situation there was a lot of
mix-up of the story first they heard
people were hearing that it was a
15-year-old
that the cops shot at so they didn't
release the full details of the story
and so people are just like oh what the
[ __ ] cops shot at some kid
and so that's what angered a lot of
people you got to get the story before
you break into yeah
and what about what elon musk got to do
with this you just
break into any place i'm against looting
all together but i think they did it
yeah yeah that's why he wanted to go to
mars yo
he had enough happened that's the purest
white flight there is
what's that you know mars he wants to
loot that [ __ ] yeah
i'm just saying you know white flight is
like black people moving i gotta get out
this is like
i'm getting all the way out bro so as
soon as he saw black panther he was like
that's enough
i gotta say that he's gonna leave on a
flying uber
no maybe the rocket will take him to
australia and then he'll take another
rocket too
real talk it's just like bro guys eyes
on the prize here
like eyes on the [ __ ] prize if you're
just gonna go and loot which does
nothing for this story
looting these innocent businesses so you
help yourself
right i'm not talking yo lowkey i'm
gonna make a defense that i don't
like making but i will say when people
in portland and i do not understand
what's going on with portland the
whitest place i've ever been to in my
entire life
i don't understand like these uh black
lives matter but we're gonna move to
this place where there are no black
lives
matter it's just like what are you doing
people in portland right
that being said they're like [ __ ] up
the courthouse they're [ __ ] up
government property because they don't
like what the government is doing
okay that makes sense
breaking into the tesla store because
the cops shot back at the guy who shot
them
that's not it guys that's not it that's
donald trump is 2020
guaranteed the more that happens
guaranteed
no i see it again i don't like graffiti
okay
[Laughter]
no that black people are going to vote
against law and order because typically
law and order makes them feel unsafe
like that doesn't usually work in my
favor whoever the law or the president
is i'm not with you
white people can do the same thing but
law and order makes them safe
everybody viscerally right now
especially i think needs to feel safe
i think black people are super triggered
by these events because they don't feel
safe
i think white people are super triggered
by the looting because they don't feel
safe it's a great point everybody's
worried
that's a great point weirdly when it
comes to like the looting and stuff i
was like just lurking
like shade room comments and like say
cheese comments just like different like
black instagram pages
and a lot of them seem to be in support
or like not in support of
the rioting and stuff or the looting in
chicago that's the thing there's
from anybody i've spoken to just black
and involved in the black movement
there's no support of looting i hate
saying it but that's
now from the beginning has been pushing
back the writing is different and we did
it in the piece yeah we broke down
specifically why
there's no nothing self-interested about
the writing
right you are not gaining anything off
of this tragedy you're using this thing
to create attention for the tragedy that
you want right when there wasn't justice
being served before when there was riot
is the voice of the unheard
a looter is just a criminal exactly
nobody's going to
move anything forward because you got a
louis vuitton bank boom
exactly but go on mark finish what
you're saying no so it just seems like
after
the killing of george floyd like in that
unrest some people were more willing to
be like you know i'm not
i'm so angry i'm going to kind of look
the other way to the whole thing or
maybe the distinction between the
writing and looting was so fuzzy that
they
it just seemed like the attitude to me
was like yeah i'm just not going to
really comment on it like whatever
happens happens
whereas with this one it seems like more
and more people are vocal about oh
you're just trying to
you know benefit off of this tragedy or
you're just trying to benefit off of
this other thing it seems opportunistic
i think george floyd
built for a few days and we all carried
that feeling of watching that happen
or just hearing about it again or
whatever this we didn't even hear about
the case and then there was looting
right like we didn't have time to be
like oh this is [ __ ] awful
what do we do with all this anguish yeah
then something happened george floyd had
are you gonna loot it to tesla what
could you lose
you can't steal no [ __ ] tesla yeah
your tesla truck
got ripped i mean how you'd steal it to
al you can't even get into your own car
sometimes
and it's yours yeah but i mean like a
regular car you could steal
at a tesla dealership tesla's gotta be
the worst car to steal though
you can't steal cause they'll drive it
right back yeah you steal it leave it in
your driveway come back it's gone
it's gone yeah bro i'm telling you that
these people
if elon musk drives all the tesla's back
to his [ __ ] lot and that makes
that's president in 2024 i don't give a
[ __ ] and he's not even american
no president of mars bro we gotta make
him the president
you